by the way i should congratulate you you
uh this was your first nomination to go
into the rock and roll hall of fame and
you actually got in
that's you go goes todd rundgren
um carol king tina turner
jay-z uh hello cool jay
it's a good year man it's gonna be
really cool who's gonna induct you
i'm not sure yet i think we're still
trying to figure that one out
we talked about this when i was on the
show when we were on the show a couple
months ago whatever
who are you thinking about be honest
with me don't don't give me any [ __ ]
howard i can't say
i can't what's with you you can't say no
he won't say anything confirmed
come on we'll see well remember pat was
saying it should be my mom
do you remember that who do you suggest
[Music]
oh that's good that's good
wow this is you're you're an original
i'm with pat i want your mother up there
who gives a [ __ ] about i went back to my
mom she was like no
[ __ ] way i'm not deducting you guys i
love that you care
yeah i mean you know it's it really is
something else
to be nominated and then it's really
incredible to be inducted you know it's
it's not the reason
why we do this stuff but hey man when
when someone comes around and
acknowledges you for the thing that
you've
like devoted your life to for the last
30 years
it feels good and chris and romney that
everybody's really
really honored and excited about it so
let me give you a tip you're the main
guy in the foo fighters you are the
reason the foo fighters exist
they let everybody get up and accept the
award you know each guy in the band gets
to say a few words
don't let your fellow bandmates drone on
and on let you
you everyone's there to see you i'm
being i'm being upfront with you i love
paddle of all the guys you know that
i know i i've been talking i i've been
talking so much for the last 26 years
that it might be the shortest speech i
will ever give in my entire life
those guys need to go up and say the
thing you know and they do you know what
i love
i love the move where some guy that you
know is the
guitarist or whatever he's not the main
guy and then he opens up
a a a sheet of paper that he's right
everything and everybody groans totally
i went to them at the rock and roll hall
of fame when i was there and i said you
know some of these guys you ought to put
on a timer
like uh have that that thing you flip
over and when the egg timer runs out
get them off the stage they're boring
the piss out of you get them up there
and play you know
you have to remind yourself that this is
a huge moment in any musician's life
you know it really is you know i know i
know you
give them a couple minutes and they say
their thing and you know yeah but i do
know what you mean
i mean the year today was inducted yeah
2014 or something that show was seven
hours long
i'm sorry and we were the last ones i
mean the e
street band were there do you know how
many people are in that band
dave by the 12th person in the e street
band i'm asleep i got to go to bed at
some point i
i mean the greatest thing was that same
year
hall and oates were inducted and uh so
the e street band like that thing went
on for a while
and then and then finally they get to
haul a notes and when when daryl hall
and john oates came up to the podium
you know the first thing they said i bet
you're glad there's only two of us